[Music]
guess who came pukara day hey George
that's where you were you know I tried
karate for like nine years right I could
have taught you that yeah more like I
could train you a few things my trainer
was mentored by Bruce Lee I was trained
by Bruce Lee himself all right ah
says you hey whatever show me what did
you learn it's not what I learned is
what I know I know how to defend myself
at any given moment night day oh my god
George how's your head
my hand is fine are you okay haha I'm
fine
George you're bleeding a lot okay don't
be a hyper contract okay it's a little
blood I punched you really hard yeah you
punch hard for a girl I hit you dead-on
obviously you did it wrong okay again
wait slow mm-hm slower have you not seen
the matrix ha ha I got you right where I
want you to tap out George it doesn't
even hurt tap out oh my god no no it's
fine you it I'm okay how about I show
you one of my moves
hey George man coming for you yeah
I
what's so nice what does that is that a
lip no George it's actually a chemical
substance known as cyanide once ingested
effects occur almost instantly causing
immediate convulsions concussion slight
in digestion death within 15 minutes 99
Georgie you missed
[Music]